هناك دعوات متزايدة
للمحاسبة في العراق بعد
حريق قاعة الزفاف الذي أدى إلى مقتل ما لا يقل عن
مائة شخص وإصابة 150 آخرين.
بدأت جنازات الضحايا.
يقول وزير الداخلية في البلاد إنه
تم اعتقال 14 شخصًا من بينهم
مالك القاعة وثلاثة أشخاص
يُزعم أنهم اعتقلوا  الألعاب النارية المضاءة في الداخل
تقول السلطات إن الافتقار إلى
إجراءات السلامة والأمن حول هذه
المناسبة السعيدة إلى كابوس
بالنسبة لنا،
ونحن على وشك أن نعرض لكم مقطع فيديو
للحظة بدء الحريق، تحذيرًا
قد يجده بعض المشاهدين مزعجًا، إنه أمر
لا يصدق حقًا، إنه مكان مكتظ  المكان
وهناك أحباء يحتفلون بزواج زوجين شابين بشكل لا
يصدق تم إطلاق الألعاب النارية
وإطلاق النار عليها أثناء الرقص وأشعلت
النار في السقف ثم ترى الناس
يبدأون في إدراك مدى خطورة
الوضع ويبدأون في الهروب للنجاة
بحياتهم والد  يقول العريس إن
العروسين نجوا